[Music]
today's question comes from scott in
vermont i know your company teaches to
never use credit cards but i'm having a
hard time letting go of mine the rewards
that i earn are very beneficial to my
family because we love to travel my wife
and i put all our utilities groceries
and other expenses on our card and pay
it off every month
what's the problem with doing this if we
never pay any interest on the card
this is an age-old question dave how
many times have you answered this one uh
six or eight thousand um the uh uh but
the thing is you just did a great
episode on uh the fine print about this
yes we did one on credit card rewards uh
and
the numbers are worse than i remembered
yeah the true cost of credit card
rewards is what that episode was called
and we talked to an ex-capital one
um lady named elena and she really
unpacked the secrets that they're using
to take your money and a lot of people
think well i'm not paying any interest
so what's the big deal dave yeah i'm not
paying any more than i would have if i
paid on it with a debit card well
obviously that's not true
okay you're not paying any interest but
here's the here's what we know the step
from the studies
carnegie mellon did a detailed study
and
using mri
and they actually determined that when
you use cash it activates the pain
centers of the brain
when you use plastic
nothing happens no brain but um
but the uh but i mean it's just left
flat line right and so what amounts to
is you emotionally experience buying
something and have a tendency to spend
less when you spend cash visualize
everybody listening right now a hundred
dollar bill in your hand leaving your
hand oh god right uh and visualize you
and here's an interesting thing too
rachel cruz brought up years ago
when you hand them the hundred dollar
bill
they don't give you
it back
when you hand them your plastic
they give it back
think about when you were a kid or
something and you were trading
you know you traded something or when
you give some you give up something to
get something that's what you do when
you pay for something with money but
when you give them your card they give
it back you didn't lose anything see how
that feels psychologically so it doesn't
activate the pain centers of the brain
plus cash just does and so here's what
all the studies tell us depending on the
area and the item you're shopping for
you will spend 12 to 18 percent more
when using plastic
than you will when using cash
when using a debt that's when using a
credit card when using a debit card
you'll even spend more i use a debit
card but you'll spend more i'll give you
another example okay
uh
george are you old enough to remember
walking inside the store to pay for your
gasoline oh yeah okay before you paid at
the pump
okay
let me tell you what happened
the last time people had to walk inside
and pay for gasoline and it doubled in
price
there was almost a revolution
they were going to burn washington dc
down
now it goes from 250
to 5
and nobody notices
because you just pick it you just plug
it in the thing pay you for your gas and
walk away the only thing you notice is
you didn't didn't seem like i got that
much gas well that's weird okay and you
drive off but if you walk into the store
the physical act of walking into the
store and pay cash and that registers
that you freaking gas is doubled i'm
gonna kill somebody you know you you
start to have this experience
and so that again shows us that there's
a behavior mechanism going on you can
take it one step further move away from
plastic used to apple pay or amazon
prime where there's no friction at all
i mean you don't have you're not even
touching something physically you're
just waving your you know you go to home
depot and you wave your little
phone across and you just bought like a
house of lumber you know but you just
waved your phone you didn't even but you
didn't emotionally experience it no
right i just bought tools i don't even
know what they do but i just waved my
little phone across i do it with my
apple watch oh yeah it's even worse oh
here's what i do dave you're going to
love this starbucks drive-thru line you
got the watch and you just handed over
like a tiny king and they kissed your
wrist as they scan it
and then you get
you get your seven dollars
we'll have a mocha exactly
and the dopamine
kiss might kiss my wrist you can't beat
it
that's the starbucks experience that's
why people go to feel like royalty
well i have noticed that with the dunkin
donuts app that i buy more donuts too
but that's how it works it's the same
thing because you don't have to pay for
it it's already paid for it's built in
chick-fil-a you can eat like half the
dadgum restaurant and not even know you
bought it so
the point being guys everybody falls for
this stuff i teach it and i catch myself
falling for it that's why disney lets
your room key
if you're staying on property work to
buy things all through disney smart that
way they can charge you 82 for a ring
coat they paid 12 and a half cents for
from china because disney causes it to
rain every afternoon on cue
but um you know it's built right into
the system nine dollar ice cream cone
right
and but your room key did it and you
don't even think anything about it it's
the happiest place on earth
and then you go to check out and you're
like oh my god i got to refinance the
house you know it's like so this is
what's going on so that that's the
problem with his little theory yeah is
he thinks he's the exception to all that
because he got some airline miles here's
the other thing
78 of the airline miles are never
redeemed
that that's 8 out of 10. that's sad
that's everybody okay
so if you do try to redeem them jupiter
has to be aligned with mars to get on
the plane i mean you have to get the age
of aquarius to get everything to work
there's all kinds of restrictions on
those points exactly and that they do
points on purpose if it was actual money
you'd know but with points you go i got
48 000 points yeah that's amazing i'm
wealthy and your point in the year that
was a fabulous metaphor you used in the
fine print episode it's like going to
chuck e cheese you know you you spend 83
dollars getting all these tickets to
trade it for a 12 and a half cent
plastic ring
you know but i got me a lot of tickets
what's your cash back and it's all free
by the way it's all free because it came
with a pizza you know
i tell people to give yourself cash back
save up for your own vacation that's
what you can do in your debt free and
you make a plan for your money i don't
have to hope at the end of the year that
we have enough points to take our family
on a trip you know we stayed ten
thousand
plus millionaires
and um
ninety percent of them eighty nine
percent of them uh were first generation
rich started with nothing
and
out of all ten thousand millionaires we
interviewed not a single one said made
all my money with my airline miles
they didn't say that wow they didn't say
you know i gamed the system i scammed
all capital one because me i'm smarter
than all capital one i mean i'm smarter
than i'm
they they spent more on that one
commercial that ran one time that i made
in a year but i'm smarter than them
the arrogance of this is unbelievable so
the fact that you think that you're
whipping their butt scott is kind of
humorous
i'm sorry son you're not whipping their
butt they're whipping yours this is how
they built buildings taller than your
house
you would love to just trade the
furniture in their lobby for your home
you know but no you've paid for every
bit of it and i know you think you
didn't fall for it but you spent more
and the number of times during your life
you fall off the wagon don't pay it on
time and accidentally slip into interest
because
a high percentage of credit card users
eventually pay some interest yeah um and
everyone thinks they're the exception
a little bit like a fishing story
you know a golfing story that one time
when i hit the ball just right you know
that one time i caught that big fish and
you spent seven million dollars trying
to get to the point you got that one
fish
you know and it's just like it's the
same crap yeah so dude follow what
millionaires do not what broke people
with theories do
and that's what people playing credit
card points are they're broke people
with theories if that makes some of you
mad out there
good that's my spiritual gift
this is the ramsey show